bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau nouveau numéro de c'est tout
le journal
nous sommes le 11 octobre voici les
titres françois fillon en campagne à
versailles le candidat à la primaire de
droite et du centre étaient hier soir au
palais des congrès de la ville où une
réunion publique et une séance de
dédicaces
nous sommes allés à saran port cette
semaine c'est la 27e édition de la
semaine du goût à l'occasion de cet
événement qui se déroule jusqu'au 16
octobre
nous nous sommes rendus au collège de la
mode à maule où les élèves ont eu la
chance de déguster un menu aux saveurs
antillaises et ensuite direction le
château de versailles qui a depuis hier
un une
un nouveau mécène et celui ci s'appelle
renault le groupe a accepté de
participer à la restauration du salon de
la paix dans un peu plus d'un mois se
déroulera la primaire de la droite et du
centre
et alors qu'alain juppé semble prendre
l'ascendant sur nicolas sarkozy
les outsideurs multiplie les
déplacements aux quatre coins de la
france c'est le cas de françois fillion
l'ancien premier ministre était pas
versailles r reportage de wilfrid richy
et camille lambert il ne pouvait rêver
meilleur public pour développer son
programme autour de la famille françois
fillon a longuement été applaudi lors de
son meeting au palais des congrès à
versailles lundi soir dans ce berceau de
la manif pour tous dont les militants
avaient chahuté son opposant bruno le
maire il a quelques mois l'ancien
premier ministre a rappelé qu'en cas de
victoire il n'hésiterait pas à réécrire
la loi taubira pour préserver la
filiation il incarne les valeurs de jeu
que je défends et principalement la
famille voilà c'est mon candidat parce
qu'il a travaillé depuis trois ans avec
acharnement et en faisant remonter
toutes les informations économiques
importants qui seuls ces informations
économiques permettront à nouveau de
libérer l'entreprise de libérer toute
cette jeunesse plafonnant à 11%
d'intentions de vote lors du premier
tour de la primaire françois fillon
s'est montré combatif lors de son
discours mais aussi lors de la séance de
dédicace de son dernier ouvrage qu'il a
accordé un peu plus tôt dans la soirée
il sondage de m'assois dessus parce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils ne valent pas
grand chose dans une primaire qui n'a
aucune référence à droite il porte sur
des échantillons qui sont en général
extrêmement modérée en tout cas
s'agissant de des gens qui veulent voter
et en plus la campagne pour les
primaires elle vient de commencer dans
le département françois fillon compte
parmi ses soutiens politiques la numéro
deux des républicains la sénatrice
sophie primas mais aussi plusieurs élus
locaux contre l homme plusieurs fois
c'est çà çà çà çà çà c'est est ce que
c'est c'est l'homme qu'il faut pour la
france où le tour de france se poursuit
pour leur candidat avant un premier
débat télévisé cette semaine premier
tour de cette primaire le 20 novembre et
selon un sondage paru aujourd'hui
françois fillon serait à 11%
d'intentions de vote est toujours
distancé par nicolas sarkozy avant tu %
et en tête alain juppé avec 42 % et
celui ci pourrait conforter son avance
hier bertrand coquard le conseiller
départemental udi des yvelines jean
baptiste à monique le porte parole du
modem 78 et cédric pemba marine adjoint
au maire de port marly et co porte
parole du modem ou 78 ont annoncé la
création d'un comité de soutien des
centres yvelinois alain juppé pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
politique toujours vous l'annoncé hier
françois de ligne et maire ps de bus en
cours
quitte son poste après 14 années de
mandature il conservera ses fonctions de
conseiller municipal et de conseillers
communautaires au sein de
l'agglomération
retour sur son parcours en reportage
d'anne laure deux ans et demi après sa
réélection françois de ligne et jette
l'épongé le maire ps de guyancourt n'a
donné pour expliquer sa démission
d'autres raisons que celles de passer le
relais à temps il ya une décision de
passage de relais et pourquoi maintenant
parce que avec d'état d'esprit que j'ai
indiqué c'est à dire celui
d'une préparation de l'avenir je sais
que c'est le bon moment parce qu'on va
pouvoir travailler en continuité
l'ancien instituteur mer depuis 2002
répète ainsi l'histoire
son prédécesseur à la mairie de
guyancourt roland nadeau c'était en
effet lui aussi démis de ses fonctions
en cours de mandat c'est un message
aussi de poursuites puisque françois de
ligne continue
je reste encore un petit peu ici je
prends un peu de champ et b ma ville
c'est ma vie de son côté l'opposition
évoque l' usure dont se serait plaint en
privé françois de lignées mais aussi
l'existence de conflits internes à sa
majorité
guyancourt pour tous des propos que
l'intéressé dément
j'ai lu là quelqu'un de l'opposition
parlant d' usure
bon on verra parce que moi je serai dans
le conseil jusqu'à 2020 il verra si si
on a une équipe usée
élu depuis 1989 françois de ligne et a
gagné la réputation d'homme accessible
grâce notamment à son dispositif
allô monsieur le maire mais c'est
surtout son bilan économique que l'on
retiendra
surfant sur l'attractivité de son
territoire il a su convaincre de grandes
entreprises d'y investir
nous sommes une ville qui atteint sa
maturité qui était encore en dynamique
et qu'un projet qui placera demain but
en cours comme étant toujours la
locomotive même pas de saint quentin en
yvelines
plus largement du bassin de vie c'est
marie-christine le tarnec 60 ans
première adjointe en charge de
l'éducation de la jeunesse et des
finances qui devrait lui succéder avant
la fin de l'année une passation de
pouvoir bien orchestrée qui permettent à
l'équipe municipale de se projeter
au-delà de 2020 mais une question
subsiste sera ce suffisant pour barrer
le passage à la droite de la saison
cette semaine c'est la 27e édition de la
semaine du goût dans toute la france
jusqu'au 16 octobre
plusieurs ateliers animations sont
proposées au public et dans les écoles
le but
éduquer les consommateurs sur les
produits et le savoir faire culinaire
nous nous sommes rendus au collège de la
mouleres à maule où les élèves ont eu
droit à un menu entier hier
depuis sept ans le département des
yvelines en charge de la restauration
scolaire et des collèges participent à
cette opération
camille lambert sur les images doubles
une première
féroce d'avocats et colombo de porc un
menu exotique pour ces élèves du collège
de la mondre pour la semaine du goût
l'établissement a choisi la thématique
des îles une éducation culturelle qui
passe aussi par la crise mais aussi
super voir la vermée découvrir d'autres
saveurs mais j'ai pas trop l'habitude de
manger ça
j'aime tout ce qui est peas et 700 plat
que je connais et que j'apprécie
naturellement le département est
responsable de la restauration scolaire
notamment dans les collèges depuis 2009
celui des yvelines participent à cet
événement national jusqu'au 16 octobre
plusieurs animations sont proposées pour
sensibiliser les jeunes est important
pour les enfants d'avoir cette éducation
au bout cette éducation aux produits
cette éducation à comment est ce qu'on
fait entrer pour produire ce justement
tous les produits qui arrivent dans les
assiettes donc l'éducation à la
consommation notamment pour cette 27e
édition la marraine n'est autre que
babette de rozières c'est elle qui a
confectionné le menu du jour j'ai pas
que les enfants un certain engouement
pour ce genre de cuisine puisque c'est
pas une cuisine qu'ils mangent tous les
jours
et ça leur permet aussi de voyager un
petit peu dans nos assiettes et de
curieux les enfants tout et ils ont aimé
ça fait la pana ils sont jeunes ils
feront fernand pale ale au bout et nous
sommes là pour ça d'ailleurs
éduquer au goût c'est aussi éduquer à
des comportements alimentaires
à partir de ces thématiques culinaire on
associe les professeurs dans la
pédagogie donc eux aussi puiss du coup
créer du lien autour de ces opérations
cette semaine les élèves goûteront aussi
à l'île de ré et à la corse
en 2010 la gastronomie française a été
inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
son chiffre d'affaires s'élève à 60
milliards d'euros par an direction le
château de versailles qui a depuis hier
un nouveau mécène et celui ci s'appelle
renault le groupe a accepté de
participer à la restauration du salon de
la paix aménageant 1680 et 1686 ce salon
fait partie d'un ensemble constitué de
la galerie des glaces et du salon de la
guerre
la vétusté du lieu a conduit le château
a lancé ce chantier de restauration
un reportage de mélanie poker c'est une
première pour le groupe automobile au
losange son président-directeur général
on a lui même fait l'annoncé hier le
constructeur français s'associe au
château de versailles et devient mécène
catherine pégard et olives et jose sont
venus vers nous pour nous parler cette
restauration du salon de la paix et on
nous en avons parlé avec notre président
avec monsieur ghosn qui a trouvé que
c'était une excellente idée parce que
renault et le château de versailles font
partie de l'inconscient collectif des
français
on a voulu aller au-delà d'un simple
partenariat mais on a sollicité donc
renault pour un soutien plus important
est vrai mais c'est nord autour de ce
salon de la paix et je crois que carlos
ghosn a voulu cette association avec le
château de versailles puisqu'au fond
c'est parler de la création c'est parler
de l'art de vivre à la française c'est
parler des talents français derrière
cette oeuvre de la future eliasson tout
au bout de la galerie des glaces se
cache le salon de la paix une
réalisation de jules hardouin mansart et
charles le brun sa dernière restauration
date des années 1950 on va nettoyer les
marmont va nettoyer
les bronzes on va nettoyer les stucs
doré et puis on va bien entendu
restaurer les peintures la restauration
des peintures a fait l'objet déjà deux
analyses très poussées et nous savons
que sous les repeints du 20e siècle et
du 19e
on a à peu près 80% de l'original de
lebrun et que cette originale de le brun
va donc nous allons essayer de le
remettre à jour c'est une restauration
conservation
il ne s'agit absolument pas de
reconstituer de recréer mais de
retrouver d'être au plus près de
l'original
le groupe automobile n'a pas souhaité
communiquer sur le montant de ce mécénat
le mécénat qui permet aussi de
bénéficier de réductions fiscales pour
les entreprises
les travaux débuteront au cours de
l'année 2017 et dureront 18 mois
on reste à versailles au château le 28
dès septembre dernier le conseil des
ministres a décidé de reconduire
catherine pégard à son poste de
présidente de l'établissement public du
château et du domaine national de
versailles
il s'agit de son deuxième mandat qui a
donc débuté le 2 octobre dernier
catherine pégard est à ce poste depuis
2011 elle avait remplacé jean jacques
aillagon
écoutez sa réaction au micro de mélanie
poker au long de ce mandat on a voulu
ouvrir davantage le château de
versailles
de toutes les manières qui soit à la
fois ouvrir des espaces on a ouvert
comme vous le savez 6000 mètres carrés
supplémentaires dans le château de
versailles
je veux parler de la galerie des
carrosses je veux parler des
appartements défi 2015 je crois qu'il
faut accentuer accélérer les projets que
nous avons engagées dans ce premier
mandat
et croyez moi il ya suffisamment de
défis à relever pour faire que il faille
se préoccuper d'aujourd'hui pour
préparer l'avenir
l'inra fête ses 70 ans cette année pour
célébrer cette date le centre de
recherche l'agroalimentaire installé à
jouy en josas a ouvert les portes de ses
coulisses au public
au programme des conférences et des
projections sur l'alimentation des
sciences animales et des démonstrations
dans les laboratoires au micro de notre
journaliste nicolas acquérir hobbit
benoît malpot le président
en du centre inra de jeu en josas nous a
présenté ses objectifs de cette journée
c'est important pour tout le monde hein
c'est important pour les chercheurs
effectivement d'avoir l'occasion ce qui
est relativement rare de montrer à tout
le monde ce qu ils font comment ils le
font en terme
en termes simples accessibles à tout le
monde compréhensible et puis c'est
l'occasion d'avoir un échange avec les
visiteurs et j'ai l'impression
qu'effectivement ça se passe bien avec
les visiteurs sont très contents de ce
qu'ils voient l'objectif c'est aussi de
dents des gens et des jeunes qui se
posent des questions sur leur devenir
professionnel part de leur montrer cas
dépistés possibilité de venir chez nous
et de travailler avec nous et qui
peuvent avoir un cadre professionnel ou
non c'est pas d'ouvrir c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
prochain journal en direct à 18 heures
demain
bonne soirée